I would work out and then I would go
into the steam room and uh but you know
I'd wear a towel yeah but some guys
didn't wear a towel and so I walk into
the steam room one day and I got my
towel on and I sit down and there's a
guy sitting across from me and you
realize there's a big difference between
hanging out in a steamy room with some
naked guys and sitting alone in a space
this big with a naked man just one other
one just one other one and so I'm not
really looking I'm not I'm not really
looking at them I'm kind of peering at
him and then I kind of go like this guy
looks [__] familiar and so I look
hard Lou Reed no Lou Reed Take a Walk on
the Wild Side
thank you
naked and his old dick is hanging down
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
[Music]